I do like how the trailer set from the
director Braveheart why we just want to
remind you the stuff that you like when
did people really like Mel Gibson
what isn't gonna give us the best chance
of of having people go well okay yeah
all is therefore no one's thinking Mel
Gibson most likely the worst you'll get
is we drank a Braveheart again Oh Gibson
that's right Mel Gibson Bridge River hey
that's how you start the conversation
back
hi guys I'm Greg if I'm John Greg is
happy today because a filmmaker actor
who I love and adore and I have been
saying needs and deserves has come back
for a very very long time and we have
possessed in a few years of me defending
why he should still be licensed about
their medication and I'm so glad to hear
this trailers getting a lot of attention
a lot of attention Mel Gibson's hacksaw
Ridge sorry spider-man Tom Hall yeah Mel
Gibson directs this movie I know that's
rest of Palmer's and it Vince Vaughn's
and his Sam Worthington on Yahoo or one
of my go-to websites
and there's several articles talking
about how this could be like this was
probably like an Oscar contender kind of
film now and I think that's really cool
because you know I feel like if we have
a hard time accepting mal in front of
the camera I feel like a great way to
like start really exactly introducing
him back into society cuz this is this
is cool because he's got his movie
coming out blood father at the end of
this month and then he has this coming
on November and hopefully like he gets a
chance to really showcases your like I
could still do both very well I heard
it's a world war two movie about a guy
who saved a bunch of people without even
killing anyone damn
what the hell are you delay captain the
way sir
why do you for what try to dust
who the hell is private docks Oh a
stream Pappy doctor put up near my
school
I can't stay here while then go fight
for me what you figure this war is is
going to fit in with your ideas well
everybody else is taking life I'm gonna
be saving it that's gonna be my way to
start I know she's a witness here from
the United States government designed to
bring them to the enemy I'm sorry
sergeant
I can't touch a gun you don't kill no so
you know go I didn't kill him does a
curve in war oh man update this is a
question religion I think this is
calvess Oh anyone else you're saying you
could go to prison no I'm Molly from
myself if I don't stay true to what I
believe with the world soap set on
tearing itself apart
don't seem like such a bad thing to mean
to want to put a little bit of it back
together private dust you are free to
run into the hellfire of that or that a
single weapon to protect yourself
damn
who's that
go get you
there's something you gotta see
who did this first the color
but if they go back up now
and then I'm gonna go up there without
you
flipping him
help me get one more interest I'm gonna
cry yeah that movie's gonna make me cry
I look like it's a 95% chance I'm gonna
like tear up during that bill I gotta
tell you I like as a fan of the Gipp
bring out the [ __ ] bring em to the
interview there's a fan of Mel Gibson
like alright when I heard that he was
doing a wolf World War 2 film my first
impression was like oh this is gonna be
cool what NIMH will still kissing Will
Smith and Mel get it Mel Gibson you know
is known you know if like after even
with Braveheart and then Passion of the
Christ Apocalypto I thought this was
gonna be like this is gonna be the real
world with this super violent is all
gonna be in German well once I get on it
will be intense like it looks like it
will feature some of the carnage what I
do really like about this is that it's
about this specific character but he's
telling a journey a story with Andrew
Garfield portraying the character Mel
Gibson directing this they're telling a
story together this one specific hero
who really stood by his morals his
values his beliefs and still managed to
save a lot of people and like I like
that story of a guy who's some consider
to be a lot considered to be a coward
and then being you know like obviously
people are gonna probably give him like
a medal at the end or something I don't
know if he dies or not I don't know the
real story it doesn't seem like it's
about the stuff that I was originally
expecting gonna like well yeah I want to
see a violent World War two films well
gives it has more of a faith II you know
streak in it than out that it looks like
what the Christian film should be more
like well yeah cuz it looks like a fish
I'm curious because I feel like Mel
Gibson has proven himself an intent
enough filmmaker that you know this will
be a compelling drama that just happens
to have some faith in it instead of
being only kind of a preaching movie he
is the guy who can bring faith-based
cinema to the masses in a way and this
is something that I feel like even if
you're not you know Christian
or whatever I think people right now
especially can get on board with a story
about trying to do something good that
thing he says about making the world a
little bit better this is a time of a
lot of unrest and and there are at least
military actions going on in the world
and so I think everyone might like to
see the story of a guy who who's stuck
to is yeah I'm killing values to make a
difference unique war hero school yeah
you know it's like a very unique warrior
like a hero who didn't fire a single guy
like that's [ __ ] crazy Matt like it'd
be nice to see like this kind of seems
like it might be a sort of an anti
violence or a peaceful story in a very
violent setting which could be really
cool yeah I feel like cuz Mel Gibson is
not gonna be shy at holding back on
violence at least I hope not
oh he definitely seems more about the
themes I'm what I'm a little concerned
about is like what you said the word
earlier being a little preachy I don't
know if this will be a preachy kind of
film chances are he's gonna be like a
two-and-a-half-hour epic often times
like the directing cinematography the
acting looks superb in this but a script
like this can get carried away too much
in trying to get its message across
cuz there's some cliche stuff in here
for sure that's the only complaint I
think about faith-based movies other
than the ideological difference it's
like a lot you see a lot of faith-based
movies and they they kind of feel like
movies second whereas this feels like it
could be very cinematic and it could be
a dramatic film that happens to feature
these themes you know regardless I feel
like Andrew Garfield really did do a lot
of work on this role and I think Andrew
Garfield is an amazing actor yes so the
fact that he's leading this film the
other cast does look great too it's fun
for the few moments we got him in I'm
like I'm not finding this to be goofy
like actually yeah yeah like that and
Sam Worthington he's an actor who I felt
like had a career that was like looking
like this for a while and suddenly it
just like went like this to me he kind
of reminds me of a young Mel Gibson cuz
this is the Australian and exam
Worthington plays these American roles
and stuff well this seems like a role
that might suit him
you know Hugo Weaving in it like not the
first time seeing Hugo Weaving in a
movie in a while well my first love
isn't Agent Smith but you go wait this
is different than what I expected it to
be I thought Mel Gibson was going to go
down with the path of what we've seen
from his last couple of films that he's
directed but seeing this I'm like
kind of harkens back more to like a
Braveheart kind of story or even when he
directed the man with two faces now with
two faces the man no face two hundred
percent right those films are about
heart and you know even like despite
what like I don't consider myself a
Catholic but I know the Jesus story
pretty well when I watch Passion of the
Christ it's a Grimm film is violent but
it's also beautiful in a lot of ways
Passion of the Christ is a story about a
hero was living by his beliefs and his
guidelines and chose not to go against
them regardless of what suffering he had
to endure so as your Garfield is playing
Jesus Christ in this movie is about huh
and he's taking a nonviolent approach to
a violent situation and trying to better
the world he's doing something
courageous and selfless annoying I mean
this could be a conventional heroic tale
with its moments of cheese but I don't
feel that the wolf ultimately outweigh
this film
I feel like this film most likely have
some of those moments yeah it's like
what I don't feel it's gonna like
completely demolish the awesome
experience this film could potentially
obtain yeah I feel like this film
probably will have a good amount of of
gripping drama to it and and some of
those war scenes you know it does seem
like they're going to confront the
reality of war there's some stylistic
shots in there like even with the
opening image of that guy like flipping
through the air on fire that's pretty
violent I think they're gonna draw that
contrast and there will be some harsh
war you know war set pieces that that
make the cost seem more real I can see
it becoming a little bit ham-fisted from
time yeah I love the movie apocalyptic
the thing about it though is I do get
the complaint that it does focus a lot
on like trying to recreate like more Mel
Gibson's fascination with history than
the actual story sometimes and I feel
like this is more about the story but
Mel Gibson is someone who I know to be
very fascinated with history so I would
like to see I'd like to see some of that
too like maybe on another trailer where
it's like well we're gonna get a
different touch of World War 2 and um
you know from Mel Gibson exploring even
more details that we haven't seen before
yeah one and and I saw in some of the
writing credits like I think they've
written some historical dramas
TV and things like that you know I'm
glad to see some history back in the
megaplex hopefully cameras gonna cut
yeah
Greg subscribe to real rejects John is
Jerry facebook.com slash blue mouse Mel
Gibson I love you